each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
great okay so now we're gonna hear from
Harry Berman on position based
cryptography thank you first of all I
wanna nevertheless thank you for
inviting me and allowing me to speak
here and being part of the summit it was
a wonderful experience and indeed I I do
want to talk a bit about the position
based quantum cryptography but while
preparing my talk I thought it would be
a more interesting to take a step back
and sort of have a more general theme so
the real title is going to be the two
applications of port-based teleportation
before before that I have to say that
I'm from Amsterdam where we already
started doing quantum computing 20 years
ago in the 95 and by now we have about
10 people working on computer science
aspects of quantum computing and we work
on the area of algorithms and also no-go
theorems communication complexity was
one of the themes that was developed
partially in Amsterdam quantum
cryptography another nice one is quantum
proofs where you use quantum mechanical
ideas to prove classical statements and
this has proven to be extremely
successful and last but certainly not
least the few cubed applications which
is a general theme of this meeting as
well and so today I will touch upon
these three areas so but first of all
let me tell you what is port-based
teleportation had do you all know what
port-based teleportation is or someone
doesn't know very good i hope i hope so
because everyone knows what
teleportation is and in teleportation
the goal is to send in an unknown state
an unknown state sigh to the other side
and the two parties Alice and Bob
usually they share an epr pair and what
happens is that Alice prepares there's a
measurement the bell measurement which
has this outcome to classical bits and
those bits
we sent them to the other side where if
you do the poly correction on the other
half of the EPR pair you have in your
hands to the state tie and so this is
all very well known in a basic building
block of quantum information now
port-based teleportation is and japanese
invention and not going to pronounce
these names but the idea is that the
task is exactly the same so again you
want to move over sorry to the other
side and you have epr pairs at your
disposal to do that but unlike normal
teleportation you have many epr pairs
now and again a measurement is done much
more complicated than the measurement
here for teleportation on one side on LS
aside and the outcome of that
measurement is a number i and the I
ranges points to one of these epr pairs
we have any PR pairs and this number I
that comes out of this measurement
points to one of these ports they're
called and it now happens that if you
look at the other side at the ice end of
the of the of the port the steps i has
appeared there so note that this is
somehow different than normal
teleportation because you don't have to
do this correction at the end but you
still have to know where where where to
collect your state sorry from so there's
no correction actually it's also not
perfect so there's a little error it may
fail so this measurement may fail but
for the rest of the talk just imagine
that this this is the primitive and
actually can make this error very small
by just having more epr pairs good good
point so let so let's compare it'll come
now so let's compare if I want to
teleport an N cubed state to the other
side it will cost me n epr pairs and 2n
classical bits now if I want to do that
with port-based teleportation it will
require 2 to the end epr pairs and
well that's one of my question so I
think it will be very interesting to
have an experiment doing small
port-based teleportation scheme but but
we can talk about how how complicated it
is and so in my talk so I thought it
would be nice to have these two
applications of port-based teleportation
the first one is to quantum position
based cryptography which will take most
of my talk and then the second if I
forget there but I'm may have been over
enthusiastic in thinking what I could
cover in 40 minutes and i will show how
to use port base teleportation to
generate stinks things that are called
non-local games or Bell inequalities
from communication complexity protocols
so hopefully I get there but the first
part of the talk is on position based
quantum cryptography and that is done
together with these guys and the idea is
the following so in 69 man landed on the
moon or so we think because there are
actually staggering I think it's
twenty-nine percent of Americans that
actually think that that never happened
and that it was staged somewhere in
hollywood and there was nobody ever
leaving the earth atmosphere and so the
goal in position based cryptography or
position verification is a key proof
that you were or that you are at a
certain location in space so can you
prove without any doubt unlike the world
the doubt that we have four men landing
on the moon that you are at a certain
location in space for example this could
be very useful because you know then for
example that the lounge missile command
really comes from the Pentagon or that
you're really talking to South Korea and
North Korea and another one is the pizza
delivery problem where your neighbor
tries to play a prank on you and all
this 50 pizzas for you and then when you
open the door you get these 50 pizzas
but you never ordered them so clearly
the pizza company needs to have a
position verification scheme in place
moreover when you have this position
verification you can use it as a
building block for other cryptographic
tasks like authentication and position
based key exchange which leads to the
nice primitive that you can send a
message to a certain location and you
can only read the message when you are
at that specific location okay so
position verification really should be
thought in 3-dimensional sphere or
switch three-dimensional world but for
the purpose of this talk I'm going to
the one dimension the line because all
the problems already are present there
and it's much easier to reason about so
let me put it on a little bit more rigid
setting so here we have our line and we
have on either side we have two
verifiers which is called verify 0 and
verify 1 and somewhere in between the
two verifiers not necessarily in the
middle there is a proffer who claims
that he is at the particular position so
this is like the men on the moon and
what I assume for now is that there is
communication that's going to occur
between the verifiers and approvers and
that communication occurs at the speed
of light knots faster and also not
slower moreover I assume that the
machines on the only locations have
infinite computation power so they can
instantaneously compute of course that's
also not true and I'm also assuming that
these two verifiers are allowed to
coordinate beforehand so they can share
and tell moment and they can share a
protocol and so what does it mean for a
protocol to be secure well it is secure
if there is no coalition of fake
profiles that pretends towards the
verifier is that there is someone at the
claimed location so in pictures it means
that there cannot be two fake profiles
in this case Ellis and Bob are the bad
guys such that they intercept messages
and somehow pretend
towards the to verify that there is
someone in the middle whereas there is
nobody so that's what you want to shield
against so let's let's try a a classical
scheme from from the 90s it's called
distance bounding it works as follows so
time flows from top to bottom and I
imagine that the verifier sends a string
X to the prover to the claimed location
and the proofer upon receiving it
immediately returns this message back to
the verifier and of course when you time
how long that takes that gives you
because of the speed of light assumption
that gives you an upper bound on how far
away the prover is from the verifier now
the other verifier could do the same
thing and also time it and that also
gives you an upper bound and these two
cones intersecting precisely one
position and that's where the approver
sits and it seems that this is a secure
scheme but it isn't because we have to
now see whether there can be an Alice in
a Bob that faked the whole thing and
that can be because what Alice can do is
the following she can intercept this X
when it when it passes by here and she
stores it and she waits a certain amount
of time the same amount of time that it
would have taken the X to go to the this
message to go to the blue spot and go
back and then once it is here she sends
it back to the to the verifier and the
same the same thing Bob does and and so
from the point of the verify as it
appears as of there is someone at the
blue spot but there isn't so this team
is not secure so let's try something a
little bit more complicated because it
wasn't really used that these two x and
y's that the x and y were somehow
together at some point so let's ask from
the provo to compute some function sum
sum function that depends both on x and
y and that outputs a and b and quickly
computes that and then
along a and B back to the verifiers and
times everything and if everything times
oak out okay then this person is at the
claimed location but unfortunately this
can also be broken and it can be broken
that as follows again Ellis intercepts
these messages this message x and not
only does she keep a local copy she also
sends on X to Bob right so she makes a
copy of the message and keeps a copy at
home and sends on the rest to Bob pop of
course does the same thing and now look
at this point in time at this point in
time both Alice and Bob have x and y at
their disposal so they can compute
quickly f of X Y which is a and B and
then send on the a and B to the
verifiers and everything looks as if
there was someone at the blue spot but
there wasn't there were these Ellison
Bob faking death position and basically
this was in 09 the proof that
classically you cannot have position
verification you can always perform an
attack you can always fake it in this
sense okay so it will be useful to think
about this problem as a game which I
call the tech game which is the
following we have our lsm Bob and what
they're trying to do is they get this
input x and y and they have to compute f
of X Y and they are allowed to send to
each other one message but this was this
copying and sent on procedure and then
after receiving the messages from from
each other and these messages have to be
sent independent of each other right
it's not that Alice can wait till she
receives Bob's message and then prepare
her message she has to send them
simultaneously and then at the end of
the day she has to output a and bob has
to output to be and as we saw that was
perfectly possible in the classical
setting because these messages were x
and y but now if we want to perform a
quantum version of this there's a
there's quite some hope because this
copying of the input if that's a
quantum information then it cannot be
copied and so maybe there's a scheme
lurking in the background that allows us
to do this nevertheless in in a quantum
way and indeed some quantum protocols
were devised here's one where we have a
random qubit being sent by the verifier
and the proof were upon receiving this
qubit an upon receiving a bit that is
sent by the other verifier to the proof
upon receiving both items the states and
the bit the proofer either if the bid is
one sends it on to the verifier and if
it's zero he sends it on to the other
verifier and then the verifier checks
the one that received the the qubit
checks that it was the qubit that was
supposed to be sent so let's study how
Ellison Bob can fake this well Alice and
Papa are allowed to send each other a
message and without loss of generality
you may assume that Bob just sent his
classical input because that's all that
he has and Alice has to prepare somehow
a state depending on her input state and
she may keep some cubits at home and
sends on some cubits to Bob and note
that if the bit is one so then bob has
to output the the qubit that Ellis
received and that means that bob has to
be able from the message that he
receives from Ellis and the fact that B
is one to produce the states on the
other hand if the bit is zero then Ellis
has to be able to open knowing that this
is p20 be able to produce from the stuff
that she left at home that somehow left
that's left over from the state produce
Phi EPS I as well and if you look at
this a little bit you see that this is
copying of information and that this is
not possible right because you can
pretend that Ellis got got 20 and let
her produce try and you pretend that Bob
had the one and let him produce try at
this point in time and indeed this was a
proof that this this was impossible and
so it seems that we have a cordon
protocol that
that is secure but actually what these
people forgot or well they thought they
thought about it but I thought it wasn't
necessary was that Ellison Bob actually
can share some entanglement and when
they do then you can actually break this
ski and here's a here's how you how you
break it it's kind of cute so we have
Alice who has try and Bob West's bit be
and what Alice does is she performs
teleportation so they share these two
epr pairs and what Alice does is she
performs teleportation unaware of what
the business and and teleports her qubit
to Bob which you can think of a
encrypted version of the of the state
that that really was there and the
encryption key is in the hands of Ellis
and what she does is she sends on these
two bits c1 and c2 now Bob who knows
that the bit is one and he knows that he
has to output the qubits in this case he
can just upon receiving this c1 and c2
he can just perform the decryption step
of teleportation and output the state
sigh so if this is what they do and B is
one they're perfectly fine but what
happens when b is 0 well Alice unaware
of course that effect that b is 0 does
the same thing as she did before so she
teleports and sends on these these these
bits c1 and c2 and Bob who now knows
that he is not the one who has to output
the qubit but Alice has to be it he just
teleports back this qubit to Ellis and
Ellis now has this doubly encrypted
qubit on her side and then when they
have done this they sent to each other
their their keys and the fact that the
bit is 0 and now Ellis who knows now
that she has to output the qubits he can
first undo the teleportation error
introduced by Bob to get back her own
state and of course because she knows
what how to undo her own teleportation
error because that was classical
information and that she could have
copied she can undo it again and Purdue
sigh so this works and it's kind of a
bit counterintuitive but it works so no
so this is all it's so this
teleportation step is really
instantaneous so and I'm telling it as
if it's a story but really it is like
one push at the button and it's
instantaneous so then more complicated
schemes were thought of and actually
also broken until we in 2010 showed that
there is a general no-go theorem for
even in the quantum case so even
quantumly you can break any scheme and
actually hubris I had a nice item in
this on this on in nature news and views
and so what is the the most general
scheme well it is something like this
the verifier 0 sent some quantum state
and the verify one send some quantum
state and the proofer has to perform
some unitary transformation on both
these two quantum states there's a
measurement or whatever and send on
ought to to quantum states tau a and
tell be that that may be entangled this
is the the most general scheme that a
quantum that you can dream up in in the
quantum world and so the attacking game
is as follows so we now do allow Alice
and Bob entanglement and they receive
this this this row a and roby they are
allowed to send each other a quantum
message and then at the end of the day
they have to produce tau a and tau B and
what we showed was using ideas from
vitamin that you can actually very much
along the lines of this back and forth
teleportation perform this task as given
here although we knew we needed
unrealistic amounts of entanglement we
needed a double exponential amount of
entanglement in the size of the of the
of the number of qubits and then shortly
after there was a very nice improvement
by veggie and curly who showed that you
can get by but only an exponential
amount of entanglement and what they
used was this port-based teleportation
so i will tell you how that works and
that is immediately the first
application that i wanted to share with
the
so here is here is the task again we
have this um we have this this row a and
what Alice does in the first step and
again this is instantaneous so I'm
telling it as a story but it really
happens instantaneous she first
teleports this row a system to Bob who
somehow receives now on his half on his
end of the EPR bears a scrambled version
an encrypted version of the state row a
and this outcome of the bell
measurements which are will be a bunch
now LS records in our pop whoo-hoo now
in his hands has this encrypted version
of row a and end the input will be he
now poor teleports using many many many
PR pairs he poured teleports this system
back to Ellis and of course there's an
out of their support I which is the two
port that contains this this this state
of course alice is unaware of which
sport is the right one so which but she
does know that there is a port namely
that the i'th one where if she first
under us the error on the on the a part
and then applies the unitary that they
have to apply on the whole thing will
give both tau and tau B so she does that
on all of these sports not knowing which
one is the right one and that will that
will produce a whole bunch of tau ace
and Toby's and she keeps the towel ace
at home and sends the Tau beasts to Bob
and note that the iphone the eighth one
here really contains the right thao a B
and so Bob that so now here's the
information the messages that i sent Bob
sends I to Alice and Bob sense older and
Allison's all the be parts that'll be
parts to Bob and now when they know that
I is the right port LS can output tau IA
and Bob can output tau I be so this is
in one shot how you can use both
teleportation and poor teleportation to
to break this or to solve this game
so it shows that there is a no-go
theorem and that you can do can get by
with a single exponential amount of
entanglement but a very natural question
I think also very important question is
is this optimal do we need really an
exponential amount of entanglement or
can you do it with much less and in
particular and I think this is very
interesting can you come up with the
protocol in the sport base teleportation
where the attack requires a lot of
entanglement but the honest proven
verifiers are efficient and they don't
need a lot of qubits so that's what I
have been looking at recently and here
is a single cubic protocol based upon
the ideas of Kent Monroe and Spiller and
the idea is the following and we have
been trying to implement this but first
let me tell you what what the scheme is
at play is a one qubit sorry which is I
encoded either in the plus one basis or
in the 01 basis or in the plus/minus
basis and this is sent to the prover and
also a classical string why sent to the
proofer and a classical string X sort of
combines all the ideas you've seen so
far and the what what approver does upon
receiving all these items he first
computes a function f of X Y but because
he has X at his disposal and y and this
f of X Y will tell him in which basis to
measure the Cubans and once he knows
what basis to measure the qubit in he
can report the outcome to both verifiers
so this is a nice scheme and provided
that this function f is easy to compute
it's also easy to implement this because
it only one cubit is at play and it's
prepared in some easy easy basis that
can be measured easily it's very
analogous to the BB 84 protocol so how
does the attacking game for lsm Bob work
well Alice and Bob are allowed to send
each other a message and then they have
to give back and the outcome of the of
the measurement of the X F X Y
measurement to this input
sorry what is the function exactly so
that's something that you can design
yourself yeah you can choose it in it
and if you want this to be practical
scheme it has to be function that you
can compute efficiently otherwise it
would not would not work and so an
interesting question that we actually
don't know really how to how to solve is
show a bound on the amount of
entanglement that you need for functions
like this so these functions are labeled
by this function that by this function f
that you have to design yourself and for
each function f there is a minimum
minimum amount of entanglement that is
needed to to solve this this game and I
want to study this this this notion e SQ
p f and we don't know how to do that
that's kind of a difficult deep question
but what we have been what we could
prove is that if you assume that the the
Alice and Bob don't have any
entanglement which actually is a fairly
reasonable assumption these days they
Alice and Bob don't have entanglement
then you can show that it is secure and
we hope actually to prove that that
actually requires an exponential amount
of entanglement to break for for easy
computable apps but that we we couldn't
couldn't the proof but it has the nice
property that you can implement it using
only one qubit so we went to talk to the
group of Nicholas ISA and and who goes
vinden in Geneva who actually performs
this BB 84 protocols and we asked them
can you please implement this for us
this this sounds like a cool thing and
then immediately all kinds of problems
popped up from doing experiments first
of all and I didn't know this but the
missus course well known for the
physicist if you shoot photons through
five where it doesn't run at the speed
of light but it runs slower it runs at
two-thirds the speed of light so that
was a bummer because for our timings we
needed that but actually that turns out
to be another problem because you can
time it in such a way that first you
send the slow cubed to the prover and
then when it arrives at the right
location you send
well slightly before that you sent your
ex and your why at the speed of light
because those are classical and those
you can actually do send at the speed of
light so this turned out to be something
that could be overcome but then that
they had another nasty surprise for us
and that that that's the following if if
I send a photon through fiber it will
arrive always there's no doubt about it
if I send something it will arrive at
the other side but what the design group
told me is no no no if you send the
hundred photons then maybe one will
arrive certainly if your distance is
large enough so that was another bummer
because it turns out and I will show you
that if you have these losses of photons
then our scheme becomes immediately
insecure it's very much like the
detector efficiency in for Bell
inequalities and here's how that works
because in the dysfunction right is that
was one bit and now what what else can
do right and sometimes these photons
don't arrived so that the classical
scheme also has to have to the
possibility of saying I I didn't receive
anything I'm not playing this time and
so what Alice does upon receiving her
input X and the state sorry she just
guesses the outcome of the measurement
so she guesses the outcome of f of X Y
and measures sigh in that basis and and
sends on a X and Z to the other side so
she sends on what she guessed she sends
on what her input was and she sends on
what the output was of her measurement
and Bob sends just his Y on to Ellis and
now when they both have received this
information they both know they can
compute whether the guess of Ellis the
initial guess was correct and if that
guess was not correct they say no don't
play I didn't receive the photon and if
it was correct well then it was
corrected and they play as if they
received it so with just one out of two
photon loss they can fold this scheme so
that's not good because actually only
one out of a hundred photons arrive so
we changed our scheme a little bit more
to instead of having one basis have a
whole bunch of bases
to code in so instead of having your
photon in 0 and 1 and this sort of the
between one you sort of have this almost
continuous possibility of basis in which
you can coat your photo then actually
they can do this in the lab so that was
that was fine and so more information
now is needed so both x and y together
say the some of them modular ok code
which which which which faces the qubit
is coded in and then this is the scheme
and then once they receive that they
measure in that basis and produce the
outcome so this is slightly more
complicated scheme and we were able to
also show that for this particular
scheme and the realistic values of
errors that occur in the protocol and
this photon losses it still is secure so
this sort of something that hopefully
will be implemented soon and that then
shows as proof of principle that when
you don't have entanglement you can have
position verification actually I'm not
going to reach my my second part
unfortunately but so concluding quantum
position verification is something that
is impossible and conditionally even in
the in the quantum case but it's very
interesting to come up with a restricted
set of schemes that that are very easy
to implement even on on nowadays on
technology that we have nowadays and
it's we can prove that it is secure when
you don't have in tenement and by
working a little bit along these lines
in coming up with somewhat more
complicated schemes we hope to get
better security parameters in particular
I think it's it's still very possible
that you have a scheme where you prove
that they only need one qubit in the
honest case but you need an exponential
amount of qubits in the epr pairs to to
break it and that will be of course a
perfectly secure scheme for all
practical purposes because we will not
have two to three hundred epr pairs ok I
guess to 240 was where I should stop so
okay well silly maybe quickly so say
something about the the other part which
is a completely different topic but it's
kind of nice as well and so first of all
does it do you know what communication
complexity is well let me so it's it's
you want to solve this problem we have
basically seen it f of X Y then you want
to minimize the amount of communication
so let me skip over that also quantumly
you can do it nonlocality non-local
games is a similar thing but there's no
communication it's like communication
complexity without communication so
Alice and Bob they share a state they
get an input performs a measurement on
that state and produce an output and
then you can look at the correlations
that are given by this conditional
probability distribution that arise from
quantum protocols and you can look at
the probability distributions that arise
from classical schemes where they have
not epr pairs but they have shared
randomness and in order to somehow
quantify these two scenarios you define
a game matrix or i call it the game
matrix or a bell inequality that tells
you give an input x and y and output a
and b was that a good output or was that
a bad output and a good output is
positive and a bad output is negative
and when you do that somewhere you score
that the runs of this protocol and you
score the ones that are good and you
negatively score the ones that are bad
and you can tweak this G a G X Y a B and
when you write down the value of this
game it's somehow an average over all
inputs X Y and outputs a B and you
compare how well you how well you
produce the hello you scored with a
relationship with this game matrix and
there's also some input probability on
your on your x and y so but don't worry
too much think of omega star as the
quantum value of this game how well can
you play it quantumly and Omega G is how
well can you play it classically
and traditionally these two things have
been compared and ratios thereof have
been looked at so you basically will
look at the ratio of how well can you
play the game quantumly and how well can
you play it classically and somehow
optimal violations are no number you can
give bounce on them but actually no
explicit game is known in in the
literature I mean we don't know an
explicit game that that gifts Oh gets
everything optimal so it's an open
problem to come up with a constructive
game that violates all parameters and
actually think it's interesting to have
these non-local games because they in
turn can be used to verify quantum
systems and they're also used in this
device independent cryptography so these
are apart from being interesting from a
physical point of view they can actually
be used in quantum computation and
quantum cryptography and so this is
something that I've been thinking about
for a long time how can we use quantum
communication complexity protocols to
get dull inequalities and if you have a
advantage quantumly how can you get a
advantage in this Bell in the quality
setting and here is here's how we go so
let's assume we have a one-way protocol
a one-round protocol where Ellison's k
qubits to Bob they have her ex and their
why and Bob has to output the value F of
XY and he does so by using his why to do
a measurement on the qubits that he
received from Ellis and that and that is
the value of F F of XY that I need to do
and I assume that the probability that
he is correct is one-half plus epsilon
and assume furthermore that no classical
scheme can achieve this so for any K bit
classical protocol the success
probability is much smaller than
one-half plus Delta right so quantumly
you can do fairly well classically you
cannot do very well so Delta is much
smaller than epsilon
so how are we going to use this protocol
to build a non-local game and here is
how it goes so here are the KQ bits of
Ellis and what she does is she port
teleports now the state to Bob and so
this was the second application of
port-based teleportation and she outputs
I and I'm describing here a run of a
protocol and then I'm going to tell you
what the correlations were that that
that were good and Bob he of course
doesn't know what I is so he performs
the measurements belonged to his input
to all of the ports so he produces a
long list of 2 to the K values be one up
to be 2 to the K and the eighth one will
actually be equal to f of X Y and this
is our exhibit precisely the
correlations of the game is fairly easy
so the game matrix on XY and outcome I
and list b is 1 if and only if the
eighth one really is the value F of XY
and it's minus 1 if the eighth one is
not f of X Y and so this gives you a
game matrix and you can now fell easily
see that if you could play these
correlations classically so if you were
able to produce these correlations
classically then that would induce a
one-round classical protocol that only
used K bits to compute F of XY and why
is that because what else just does she
she generates this I classically and
sends it on to Bob and that is just log
of 2 to the K and that's just K bits of
information so this sort of port bias
teleportation allows you to to to
produce a non-local game that cannot be
won classically so if you work it out
you see that the classical the condom
value of the game is at least epsilon
and the classical value is at most
deltas it's we do it like this it's
really this bias how much more than a
half you you win
and so you get this nice ratio and
actually let me quickly go through this
I mean of course you want to do this for
multi rounds and then there's a problem
but we solved it so I'm not going to
bother you with what the problem is but
I'm telling you that we solved it here's
the the final slide so if you have a
multi round protocol for which there's a
quantum advantage over a classical
advantage then you can get a violation
of Bel inequalities and there's a little
bit of a loss so if it's an hour around
protocol we require that the classical
protocol is even better when it has our
times K bits of communication so now you
can apply it to all kinds of
communication games where is a big
advantage and so that's what we did but
yeah so we did get some new Bell
inequalities that got almost optimal
violation so that that's nice but the
drawback is that it actually required a
lot of entanglement again so remember
this port base teleportation used a lot
of entanglement well the sort of is
killing us on this side but in theory
this gives you a general method to
produce a bell inequality from a quantum
protocol and that's where when I stop
their questions so with the experiment
I'm kind of curious eyes since you're
going in fiber are using time bidding
coding for the photons no just
polarization okay cool so then the next
question about time bidding coding have
you considered taking a look at that
because it sounds like it could be very
interesting because the quantum data the
operations now are kind of having space
spread over the time axis so the timings
could be affected by what Alice and Bob
are doing yes so we did think of time
bidding and i've already had a nice
scheme where you had like
multiple bins and you you've got some
nice interference and then they did the
experimental is that geeza and and who
go looked at me and said we're not going
to do this interferometer with these
long arms and I did that for my thesis
and I'm not going to knit again so so
you're right it gives you much more
possibilities because you can have more
inputs but they said nope but maybe we
have to push harder question about the
position based protocols you mentioned
there's a choice of function for which
the honest parties just require one epi
up here and as honest parties require an
exponential number correct yeah well the
honest one actually no not even an epi
pen not even a bianchi went right but
like is that seems very non graceful the
way this degrades in terms of the
position right you wanna you want to
basically lie about your position you
need an exponential number but if I just
want to lie a little bit it's like I
want to do a little fib about my
location then I also need to spend an
exponential amount or does it degrade
somehow with the position I'm I'm trying
to lie about and I mean I mean let's
assume that you still have infinite me
because if your computation takes a
while it's really like a little bit of
an epsilon bowl around to thing but say
suppose that you're outside of that bowl
yes then you would require exponential
wow we didn't prove it but then it
doesn't really matter where you are even
an epsilon away from the true location I
immediately have to spend in it yeah
because then you need two parties and
they timing wise if they're sort of far
away right then they don't have enough
time to send each other stuff they
require this this this antenna okay yeah
attacked by analogy at night you see you
may not distinguish a bush from a person
what if a person moves that's much
easier to just and it's not about
usually right oh you had too much to
drink here so if your approval is not
standing still ah but moves good
question yes so then it's Dennis again a
different scenario and so we assume that
you but you have assume that you are in
the White House and you're not moving
to another location in Washington so
that may break but you're right it's
that something something else but then
what would you prove that I I mean
constantly you monitor the location yeah
then maybe also at the known time you
happen to be on the mood well I mean the
moon way to imagine where this verifiers
have to sit circle around the moon right
even people not serve them will believe
but moving around this is indeed
something to look at great well let's
think Harry again and then